beaucoup moins à près de chez-vous
carrément loin au nord l'arctique sa
population les inuits autrement dit les
eskimos une galerie de strasbourg
l'empreinte présente à partir
d'aujourd'hui des dessins et sculptures
de l'art eskimos à cette occasion un
groupe de chanteuse a interprété un
échantillon de la musique traditionnelle
inuite
un moment rare et surprenant
jean-françois de l'isi jacques rigaud à
quelles occasions et ce qu'elle chante
c'est ce que c'est pour des fêtes est ce
que pour cdc pour des événements
particuliers
m
il nous resterait un motel une rocher
depuis l'arrivée des inuits la naissance
des inuits je crois que qu'on l'avait
commencé c'est un jeu spore des inuits
le jeu
qu'est ce qu'ils racontaient ce qu'ils
racontent une histoire y avait une
rumeur
gerry barr on raconte rien ça fait
partie de la culture on continue ce que
nos ancêtres avaient commencé pourquoi
est ce que le sommet de face à face il
faut faire le captain jack comme ça
qu'est ce que c'est le cas de john sinon
la cathode cas et le canada
ça c'est le nom de chant ce qu'on a ce
que vient de faire
pourquoi ce qu'elles sont si sérieuse
alors que tout à l'heure elle rigolé à
s'amuser en train d'emmener sérieux avec
nous